selfie from Halla is a 2018 horror movie
that builds upon the viral YouTube short
of the same name the movie takes the
aesthetic of a piece of technology
similar to the ring or unfriended and
subverts it to fit the horror genre
there's a lot to unpack from the film
and throughout this video I'll be
discussing the movie in full detail as
well as giving my opinion on what the
film represents there will be heavy
spoilers so it may be worth skipping
this for now if you want to go in with
fresh eyes with that out the way I'm
definition and I ruin the movie so you
don't have to Julia an online blogger
travels to the u.s. to visit her cousin
Hannah and becomes extremely ill upon
arrival after Hannah researches her
cousins videos on the Internet
she discovers that she's been listed as
deceased by many online outlets with her
cause of death remaining a mystery on
hit by a mysterious shadowy figure
Hannah slowly doubts into the dark web
where she discovers more and more
twisted things about her cousin's past
this deep dive into the Internet's
underground attracts unwanted attention
and Hannah foolishly gives up details
about her personal life in order to gain
entry to information on what can help
her cousin taunted by a mysterious voice
over the phone
Hannah is drawn to the black room which
is an area of the web that can draw
forth a murderous ghost should all of
the content that is located on it be
watched as Julia's illness evolved into
an unnerving possession things worsened
by Hannah as she is attacked and bound
in her home her attacker is revealed to
be the mysterious voice on the phone and
he explains that once 13 selfies are
taken of her the demonic force will
appear and kill her this is the one that
was haunting Julia and it brings death
to all who attempt to summon it
the attacker attempts to take pictures
but is stopped in the last second by
Hannah's friend Cameron he frees her but
also admits to watching 13 selfies in
the black room unable to rest he traces
the signal of the videos to an abandoned
house that he and Hannah search they
discover a video of a doctor describing
a catatonic killer that has been linked
to several murders in the video they see
the doctor waking the killer
his vegetative state by showing him
images on a screen delving deep into the
house they discovered the hanging body
of the killer and an apparition appears
and attacks them before the 13th selfie
which is a hanging man chokes on the
noose after the hanging man's attack
Hanna finds herself trapped in a
picturesque landscape where the 13th
selfie tortures her as it fades to black
personally I take selfie from Hell to
represent a lot of things about
modern-day social media all of the
characters wish to make themselves
appear in a certain way in their selfies
yet the shadow still haunts them rising
anxiety and depression rates are often
attributed to pressures of social media
and the darkness that surrounds them is
similar to this Julia particularly wants
to present a happy image to the world
and this signifies pretending to have a
perfect life on social media bust her
demons hide below the surface her
boyfriend is dead and the demon stalks
her but she still wishes to carry out
the masquerade on social media and it
highlights how fake everything is
becoming this is further cemented by the
film's ending in which Hannah Julia and
Cameron believe that they are living in
a picture-perfect world all the while
secretly being trapped in a world of
torment metaphorically it highlights the
dangers that come from lying to
ourselves and others about how perfect
everything is and how this opens us up
to pressures that involve constantly
trying to live up to standards that are
unattainable it's an interesting take
for me but one that unfortunately falls
flat in the film slightly due to the
mediocre acting and poor resolve I
expected more from this film so cannot
really recommend it as such so what do
you think of selfie from hell did you
watch the original viral video and you
think viral videos should just stay by
rule videos comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and subscribe to my
channel I break down films like this
weekly and they'll definitely be
something on here that you love if
you're a fan of film recently I
discussed the ending of Slender Man so
make sure you check that video out next
linked at the end of this one thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you